esta huelga nacional que ha sido
convocada por tres días y que comenzó
hoy no solamente está llamada a recordar
a maxam Y esa joven kurda que hace ya
dos meses fue detenida por la policía la
moral y dos días después falleció en un
hospital de Teherán sino especialmente
para recordar a miles de personas que
hace tres años en el 2019 en esta misma
fecha en el mes de avan como se conoce
por el calendario persa salieron a
protestar por el aumento repentino del
precio de la gasolina y En aquel momento
la represión si bien no se sabe si fue
mayor si fue mucho más concentrada en
pocos días y bastante violenta algunas
versiones hablan de más de 300
fallecidos y otras como la que citó la
agencia de noticias routers que hablaba
con Fuentes gubernamentales locales
gente que habló fuera of the récord
hablaba de 1.500 muertos en aquel
momento así que querían recordar a estas
personas estuvimos dando vueltas por
Teherán y vivimos parte de los sectores
comerciales parcialmente cerrados
también veíamos mucha gente caminando en
la calle intentando unirse y cuando se
unían pues cantaban esos eslóganes que
se han convertido en símbolos de estas
protestas incluido muerte al dictador y
también veíamos muchas mujeres sin el
velo como acto de protesta y está huelga
es importante para quienes están en las
calles Desde hace dos meses porque una
de las críticas que hacían al sector
económico es que no se habían arriesgado
a apoyar estas protestas la indignación
cada vez es mayor la rabia es cada vez
mayor pero muchas personas se preguntan
Cómo poner en riesgo sus negocios o su
vida económica por algo que no saben qué
va a pasar así que para quienes
protestan lo que sucedió hoy ha sido
bastante importante